[Music]
[Music]
so we're here in the heart of downtown
Las Vegas right next to the famous El
Cortez I mean you got the strip those
are all the new casinos but this is
where it all started places like Piero's
that was filmed for casino El Cortez
where you can still play blackjack with
only two decks and also La cometa
great place for tacos we're gonna come
in here you're gonna hang out with Jamal
Murray
what up Jamal that was good there right
good a season two hey they got us twin
doubt how the bounce instinct
cool the performance eating shoot so I
ordered ahead I got a few things out
passed or tuna tostada fish taco queso
fundido so if I was gonna start I would
start with the raw fish here go ahead
let's let's do some tuna tostada first
yeah you stepped up this year how do you
feel about the season I felt real good
two years in a row for me that we missed
all the plans I want with one game so
yeah he's trying to go over that home I
try sometimes queso fundido look
this is really good my dad was my
influence he's my coach you know my
trainer and my best friend know what was
some of your influences some things you
got captured really my mom taught me all
of my skills but they're like wisdom the
calmness the centering it comes from my
dad
my dad was really tough on me very
disciplined your dad was a big part of
your training right yeah eating a lot of
fruit you know he taught me a lot of
mental side of it do a lot of meditation
Bruce Lee was his favorite fighter and
he always loved the mentality so yeah
how do you think like that
alternative training like works its way
on at the court I think it works best
because it worse you know for your life
first it works good to know your
strength and how you do pain how you
view you know sacrifices and I grew up
with no cable no and yet no phone all
that so it was kind of democratic
mindset where I couldn't complain I
couldn't come up with excuses to to get
out of the jail I had to just do it and
if I do it yeah you trained your entire
mind and body that's one thing I'm
curious for you don't want to be through
the drills now that's what we do you
know we on and off the court
[Music]
I could do all of it but the roll but
I'm gonna try this oh yeah hey I like it
I like it okay
we doing your dad's blindfold drills
right here there's a nail in the pizza
line right that's what you want to put
your toes see you behind that up make
sure elbows tucked in locked in
you just wanna keep that same for every
time you go up so you don't lose where
you at all right all right perfect
is that comfy got it still way off
here's how I do I'm a flirt online no I
don't have to have it all yeah just put
them fall in line take over dribbles
look at it once I put it on I already
know where I'm shooting it so I just
shoot straight
yeah I'm on the nail bucket bucket off
right still my new shooting coach shouts
to adidas it's the greatest athletic
moment of my life let's see we could
replicate this moment here datura
rollers into a row oh yeah oh yeah you
buy the house of Bounce instinct shoot
you free throws with a blindfold make
the NBA